il y a deux semaines de vie était
présenté dans l'émission heureuse comme
la révélation de la soirée un jeune
homme de 20 ans qui devant les caméras
du show a livré une prestation très
remarquée que les politiques
[Musique]
compétent si le choix de la chanson
suicide social de orelsan a fait grincer
quelques dents parmi les téléspectateurs
les côtes venteuses ce sont tous les
quatre tournées mais c'est sur twitter
que la vérité à polémique a éclaté
lorsque des internautes ont déterré dans
un tweet du jeune homme
les tweets jugés racistes et
provocateurs qui l'a écrit lorsqu'il
avait 17 ans immédiatement la production
et la chaîne ont décidé de l'évincer du
programme faire taire la polémique
alors tf1 est elle bien fait d'ex-urss
de vie pour ces anciens tweet ce soir il
est sur notre plateau pour nous
expliquer cette décision
merci je dis merci à de viévy d'être sur
le plateau parce que il était obligé
c'est courageux à lui d'être sur le
plateau parce que c'est vrai qu'on n'a
pas été tendre avec lui après la
diffusion de ces tweets et vraiment il
ya beaucoup de gens bien entendu qui ont
été durs avec vous merci d'être là
devant vous pour la vie
merci alors déjà pourquoi vous vouliez
venir ce soir
enfin pourquoi vous avez accepté de
venir ce soir enfin c'est ce que vous
avez en parler faut parler des choses
qui qui tourne et qui sont pas les bons
c'est vraiment faussé fallait s'exprimer
ça veut dire les choses pour bleu on
voit là que vous pouvez vous nous
expliquer votre vérité votre sentiment
voilà sur tout ce qui s'est passé avant
avant qu'on en parle j'aimerais juste
qu'on revoie votre portrait dans the
voice et c'est vrai que c'est un gros
talent je vis vis on se rappelle aussi
de ménage qui était un énorme talent et
qui est toujours un énorme talent et ses
tweets fait voilà se battent entre eux
17 ans 18 ans 16 ans peuvent gâcher une
carrière et c'est pour ça que ci que je
vivais là soit parce que c'est vrai
qu'il envie de s'expliquer sur cette
polémique regarder le portrait de vie
salut je m'appelle bolivie j'ai 20 ans
je suis rappeur streamer c'est à dire
que je rappe devant des centaines de
personnes sur internet mais aujourd'hui
je rappelais sur zone
c'était des années des années des années
que je fais ça tous les jours
aujourd'hui je pose des vidéos je fais
aussi des live c'est à dire que les gens
me regardent en direct en train de
chanter rapper ils me proposent des
petits sont dans le tchat
merci donc voila c'était donc le
portrait
quand vous voyez ce portrait ça ça vous
fait quelque chose c'est ouf
si quelqu'un internet tu le suis désolé
depuis 2010 j'ai commencé à pousser de
petites vidéos et tout est là je suis
sûr que vous vous alors tout a commencé
le samedi soir lors de la diffusion de
la prestation de vie vous aviez choisi
d'interpréter suicide social un titre
d'orelsan sortie en 2011 alors c'est la
production qui les pros qui vous avait
proposé plusieurs titres ou c'est vous
qui avez demandé ce titre là non ils
m'ont proposé parce que moi j'y suis
allé avec avec un titre mais c'était
savait que ça allait pas passer à la
télé parce que c'est trop d'absents
entre autres au rap quoi mais du coup il
me proposait sont là et comme 500 qui
avait déjà repris il ya très longtemps
en 2014 si je dis pas de bêtises
l'époque j'avais donc c'est bien la
production qui se vide a demandé voilà
ce qu'on avait dit à la presse et lui
après c'est en voilà c'est ce que la
production suggère des titres mais il
est quand même de bon ton les choisir ne
saurait trop leur dire non en vrai moi
lui ça lui allait bien
c'est quelqu'un que je suis depuis que
julien donc ça m'a fait limite c'est à
demi-temps honneur de faire ça sur tf1
parce que c'est un sont là ça sera
sûrement c'est ça c'est un sont même ici
on en a parlé on était très étonné de
voir ce sont sur tf1 puisque les paroles
de la chanson les bisounours et leur
pouvoir de l'arc en ciel qui voudrait me
faire croire qu être hétéro c'est à
l'ancienne tellement tellement
susceptibles pour prouver que t'es pas
homophobe faudra bientôt que tu suces
des types
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable de voir
ce genre de paroles sur tf1 c'est
d'orelsan en 2011 album le chant des
sirènes et déjà la chanson avait fait
polémique
et c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens ont
parlé après ils ont dit que c'était
inadmissible de voir ça sur tf1 vous
avez compris la polémique déjà autour de
la chanson pas du tout ouais je
comprendre il faut apprendre à lire un
texte quoi c'était faux faux faux juste
sur le texte le comprend et sait ce que
beaucoup de gens n'ont même pas fait
l'effort de faire alors les médias ont
souligné votre prestation
le figaro aux russes sera peur d'eux ils
iront voûte le jury du télé crochet
the voice sur le rap deux vies sur
suicide social d'orelsan a retourné le
jury voilà tout c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des articles partout et ensuite la plus
grosse polémique celle qui a bouleversé
votre avenir dans l'émission et qui a
énormément fait parler c'est celle de
vos anciens tweet dès le lendemain le
dimanche
d'anciens tweets sont ressorties sur les
réseaux des tweets que vous aviez écrit
entre juillet et septembre 2010 est vous
avez quel âge à l'époque donc 17 ans est
en 17 ans des tweets parfois ironique
très provocant qui ont scandalisé
beaucoup de monde
il ya eu des commentaires jugés
homophobes voilà je suis pas [ __ ] sous
race quelle est la différence entre un
arabe et un saut de merde le saut mdr et
c'est de l'humour 1
qu'est ce qu'un arabe sans main un
antivol c'est vrai que quand on lit ces
tweets on les a lus ici
moody's de vie pour nous ça a été très
très dur de voir ce genre de tweets de
lire ce genre de tweets ça avec ses ça
paie ni énormément de personnes qui vous
ont regardé certainement sur the voice
et qui vous ont trouvé un talent immense
et qui ont été extrêmement déçue je vous
dis tout voilà parce que c'est vrai que
nous on n'est pas là pour pour enfoncer
les artistes au contraire vous avez un
talent énorme et nous on aimerait qu'une
chose c'est que ça cartonne pour vous
voilà je vous dis franchement
et quand on a vu tous ces tweets on
était téléspectateur lambda lambda qui
comme eux chez eux se sont dit ah ouais
on est on est on est déçu on est triste
parce qu'on aimait jeune homme on
s'attache à lui en trouver qu'il a un
énorme talent et ça a déçu énormément de
monde qu'est ce que vous avez à leur
dire ce soir
moi je m'excuse déjà je tiens à dire à
tous les personnes qu'on complète aux
français c'est jusqu'au choquant a
carrément bas je m'excuse je sais quoi
c'est c'est une connerie vous avez voulu
faire le malin à l'époque moi j'étais
sûr j'étais sur internet avec des potes
on rigolait et c'est du lourd c'est
d'humour nul c'est du second 3e 10e
degré c'est nul quoi comme moi c'est sûr
que tu ramènes je suis carrément
d'accord jarvis a déjà je me rappelais
même pas les heures prestées et j'ai vu
ça j'ai voir ce que c'était il ya plein
de gens qui se sont sentis jaloux
aimeraient blessés qui sont sentis visés
pour ça que je voulais venir ce soir ici
c'est pour m'excuser et surtout pour
faire comprendre aux gens je suis pas
raciste homophobe pédophiles misogynie
il ya toute la tournée il ya même des
médias compris par je suis rien de tout
ça je suis tout ça et c'est pour ça que
je suis du sort
gilles verdez qui est vous avez été
assez virulent avec willy vie
qu'est-ce que vous avez lui dire ce que
soient les tweets pour moi même vous
avez dit quand conneries d'ados ou
vannes déplacer pour moi c'est pas
acceptable c'est trop choquant moi j'ai
une question à vous poser une chanson
polémique très polémique d'orelsan que
la production vous incite à chanter des
tweets dont on sait qu'ils existent vous
vous en souvenez plus mais on sait
qu'ils existent
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir été entre guillemets de jeter en
pâture par la production de the voice à
un audit au rac vous ne pouvez plus
maîtrisé après je pense pas je pense pas
parce que la prod nous dit bien faites
attention à vos tweets tout ça et on met
ça fait depuis 2013 regardez là là je
vais là je vais répondre à des mobiles
il aurait dû regarder à domcile sûr et
certain mais c'est pas la production qui
a écrit les tweets de vie donc voilà
après il aurait dû vérifier avant ça
c'est sûr et certain
mais c'est lui le seul responsable de
ces tweets et ce qu'il dit il et c'est
pas la production qu'il appelait il ya
trois ans qui tu vas perdre au bruit
dans trois ans tu vas faire des tweets
polémique
une autre exception non non mais moi je
vous dis je suis pas souhaiterions
j'aimerais avoir ce soir le sentiment de
vie parce que je vis je le vois sur les
réseaux sociaux
tout le monde dit ces tweets sont
immondes c'est inadmissible
est ce qu'on doit est ce que vous les
deux qui m donc cette fois les 3 à 20
milliards 4 c nicolas pernikoff vous
vous dites quoi de ça en fait moi je
m'excuse parce que j'ai été très
virulent il ya quinze jours trois
semaines et un moment donné c'est
l'histoire la frontière de l'ain team
s'étale il faut remettre dans le
contexte au moment où ça a été fait
puisque j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
s'était fait à un moment où il avait
très peu de copains dans son réseau
social et c'est une connerie de jeunesse
fer que moi j'ai un gamin de 17 ans est
une vraie connerie de jeunesse et ce
qu'ils méritent la double peine c'est la
question parce que le mec a un talent
mais monstrueux mais mes amis c'est
maintenant mon feu selon l'avocat c'est
ici
il avait un talent et une personne mis à
part met d'accord d'accord il s'est
platement excusé
il vient de sortir grandir où il fait
une chanson pour s'excuser avec des mots
mais très juste
est ce que à un moment donné un môme de
17 ans mérite la double peine je veux
dire il le dit lui même il n'est pas
raciste il n'est pas homophobe il a
honte de ce qu'il a fait ou les quoi qui
se met par terre et qui vous supplie de
le laisser faire son métier
quand tu as un mec a du talent comme ça
il faut savoir de tan tan pardonner et
pourtant il ya quinze jours j'ai été
comme gilles verdez j'étais beaucoup je
vous laisse je m'en suis voulu après
j'étais beaucoup trop sur medal aussi
alors on aurait dû pardonnez pas oui
bien sûr mais là aussi on aurait une
part donné l'homme tombé sur un os comme
enel ont leur briser 150 fois c'est
toujours lié de l'histoire c'est ou non
maintenant il ya plus de nuances
on peut plus discuter comme le plus
échangé on peut plus se justifier donc à
un moment donné oui un peu de nuance
il faut écouter les gens et puis essayer
d'avancer avec son temps moi moi j'ai
été aussi très dur avec mai 2010 c'est
vrai que ce qui est terrible histoire
c'est que c'était un vrai choix était
une vraie posture de prendre cette
chanson qui est totalement annulée par
les truies parce que du coup ça avait
une résonance terrible à la chanson les
bases mec là en fait il est il est comme
un non mais c'est juste de fêter ça a
été une réaction et je trouve ça dommage
après moi j'ai été très dur sur ménages
des effectivement il fallait faire une
sanction et je pense que tf1 ne pouvait
pas ne pas sanctionner très honnêtement
après c'est vrai que c'est un gâchis et
je fais effectivement m'attendais pas
non plus il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
avancent mais en même temps voilà mais
c'est vrai que la résonance des deux
était très difficile à entendre
voilà alors on va passer à la dernière
partie de l'émission et je vis vis vous
avez été virés donc de the voice puisque
tf1 n'a pas souhaité s'embarrasser d'une
polémique comment ça s'est passé
c'est la production qui vous après ils
m'ont appelé ils m'ont appelé le
lendemain que ça tourne ça va tourner le
dimanche soir
d'accord le lundi matin vous avez un
duel lundi matin on m'a appelé deux qui
l'a produit de la prod qui voit là bravo
de la preuve qu yves diba bon tu t'en
doutes c'est terminé c'était un mineur
entre nous et je comprends le choix
ce que vous aviez vous comprends le
choix d'aller pleurer vous avez mangé
pas pleurer parce que je m'étais fait à
l'idée de le dimanche soir que mais
comme ces tweets vous saviez qu'ils
allaient sortir un moment ou pas mais je
savais même pas qu'ils les avaient posté
non jeu
carrément je les aurai supprimer sept
ans et je les avais vianney au téléphone
oui je sais ce que vous a dit vianney je
sais pas si je veux qu'un amour de mecs
c'est un super mais il a donné de la
force que j'avais bien compris que
c'était de l'humour parlant son faux pas
le foot dans la sauce je suis pas prêt à
ça il faut pas le prendre à d'autres
jeunes élus par sms également vianney
c'est quelqu'un qui a un coeur énorme
seulement voilà je vous le dis c'est un
garçon forcément il cautionne pas du
tout les tweets 2e vie il me l'a dit
c'est voilà c'est nul c'est oui c'est ça
le fait pas rire c'est nul mais vianney
c'est un mec qui a un coeur énorme et
qui voit aussi le talent de vie et qui
voit là à vianne et c'est un mec qui
pour le pardon qui est pour voilà il
comprend qu'on puisse faire des erreurs
il aurait dit pareil pour mesnel voilà
et il était très très embêté par cette
histoire
ça l'a énormément peiné à vianney parce
qu'ils croient énormément de vie et ses
tweets et voilà ça ça la salle à payer
parce qu'il était déçu de voir ses
tweets est aussi très triste de le voir
quitter l'aventuré parce que pour lui
c'était un immense talent et qui croit
beaucoup en toi et il c'est vrai que
vianney voit la c1 c'est un amour de mec
oui au mois d'août la décision de tf1
elle est honteuse ils vous ont choisi
pour votre côté super mais j'aurais pu
et aurait dû regarder la mer ils vous
ont choisi pour adultes et subversif il
vous donne une chanson polémique
au bout d'un moment ils veulent mettre
du rap en prime sur tf1 qu'ils assument
ils vont mettre valdes en coach qui est
un artiste qui est mortelle qui a aussi
des textes hardcore qu'ils assument au
bout d'un an ça c'est pour la chanson
ensuite pour les tweets c'est de
l'humour c'est de l'humour pas drôle du
tout catastrophique mais c'est de
l'humour
il ya plein d'artistes plein de
personnalités qui ont déjà eu des propos
racistes homophobes hyper déplacer et
premier degré et qui sont encore au top
aujourd'hui
là on va sanctionner un gamin de 20 ans
qui avait 16 ans à l'époque on va lui
briser sa carrière
j'espère pour vous qu au moins ça ça
fera parler de vous et vous ferez opérés
par des producteurs parce que c'est une
honte ce qui vous arrive franchement
c'est honteux
géraldine non mais je suis d'accord avec
toi guillaume sauf que là il ya la
jurisprudence mais neil mellor intenable
en fait un peu prier pour cette juriste
ça ouais on est de la même manière que
moi je trouvais que c'était normal
qu'elle soit exclue je trouve que du
coup c'est normal même si vous avez
énormément de talent que vous soyez
exclus et j'ai envie de vous dire il ya
une vie amoureuse aubry
en fait vous l'avez montré c'est à dire
que vous allez rebondir parce que vous
avez beaucoup de créativité
nicolas pernikoff l'a dit vous avez
écrit un titre magnifique grandi
et voilà et vous allez faire autrement
et autres choses sens vice et si ça se
trouve ça va être une route magnifique
mais moi j'en ai marre aussi con mais
toujours tout sur le la jeunesse oui
parce que malgré tout à 17 ans né à une
année du droit de vote et arrêtons
d'infantiliser la jeunesse je suis
désolé on a le droit d'être éduqué on a
besoin d'être responsable en un endroit
aussi de planes écrire n'importe quoi et
n'importe comment
17 ans on est quand même un adulte mais
la question c'est ce que les tweets d'un
gamin de 16 ans qui a 3 follower ont une
vraie résonance et alors là je dis pas
que c'est bien ce qu'ils ont fait je dis
je dis juste la vraie question c'est
est-ce que ces tweets qui ont été
postées ces blagues pas drôles ça a
vraiment blessé des gens quand il avait
trois abonnés à mon avis la réponse est
non non mais ça jean appartient alors
main sincèrement je me dis que quel ado
n'a jamais fait de black d'humour noir
entre ses potes à dire au lycée ses
terres et mai car il l'a jamais vu
pareille pense pour se rendre
intéressant pour faire rire les copains
c'est toujours la même chose c'est
toujours ça je le comprends je le
comprends vraiment et déjà qui se prend
tout internet sur le de crois moi je
sais ce que c'est j'étais la première
victime de ça tu le sais tu te prends
tout internet sur deux sur le dos en
plus de ça la prod te dire effectivement
c'était la preuve devant les tout avant
pourquoi les gens pour 8 heures l'ont
fait c'était à la prod de le faire pas
aux gens de twitter alors il ya des gens
sur twitter qu'ils iront voir les
commentaires être un adolescent
ça justifie pour un mec blanc mais pas
pour une jeune fille voilée donc simenel
a été viré pour des propos de quatre ans
en arrière c'est pareil pour lui je n'ai
pas d'avis sur sion doit virer une
personne un show télé pour des propos
tenus il ya plusieurs années
par contre la différence de traitement
avec ménez aurait été intolérable c'est
évident sur wii je vis juste qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire aux téléspectateurs
joue je vous laisse la parole parce que
c'est vrai que je vous lis moi j'étais
extrêmement peinés par c'est oui comme
tous les téléspectateurs
c'est vrai que géraldine ont cessé
qu'est-ce que vous avez alors dire ce
soir moi ce soir déjà je m'excuse je
m'excuse clairement je vous dis
sincèrement je m'excuse pour si ça a pu
blesser choqué et s'il vous plaît ne me
mettais pas ses blagues comme ce que je
pense actuellement je suis pas raciste
homophobe et le fils ses branches le
message que je veux faire passer
je comprends que la prod mais je dirai
pas ce que ça joue aussi en l'image de
la prod et je comprends carrément mais
je suis pas raciste homophobe pédophiles
ça je veux clairement tout le monde le
comprenne pas ce que risque c'est de la
merde c'est oui bah oui c'est de la
merde c'est bien sûr c'est de la merde
c'est nul vous avez fait elle est
magnifique c'est comme ça
par la créativité on comprend exactement
maintenant votre message et ont été
clairs en fait vous êtes malheureux
aujourd'hui celui du rebond d'hier bah
oui toujours rebondir sadry de rebondir
et de montrer que vous n'êtes pas la
personne voilà si on a pu croire que
vous étiez à cause de ses tweets et vous
allez travailler pour essayer de thuram
en écoute avait été contacté vous avez
reçu des appels ou des maisons de
disques bref un peu en bord de mer merci
en tout cas c'était courageux de venir
et si rémy peut pas y avoir deux poids
deux mesures entre eminem vivier en tout
cas merci d'avoir été là